as always this past thursday is brought
to you by gray block pizza great block
pizza it's that piece of establishment
when you're driving around and you're
thinking about doing crime or you know
even thinking about just sleeping in
your car doing nothing and not even
taking care of your family change those
feelings go to grey block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard get that hit or boy thank
you guys for joining us can you hear me
Nick
alright we have our second guest ever
that is going to come in a studio in
just a moment and this man is a
beautiful man and I'm gonna tell you
that out of the gate and this is mr.
Tate Fletcher and just so you know he
has a really solid MMA background and
I'm reading some of this information he
started at one of the best MMA gyms in
the world and that's Jackson Winkeljohn
from there he became one of the best
grapplers in the world becoming a
champion he played an important role in
shaping MMA he competed on the UFC's
reality series The Ultimate Fighter but
I don't even know him from any of that I
know him he's a he's a Hollywood
stuntman and I know him through through
self-help and that sort of thing and
just you know I have not had many
conversations with him but everyone I've
had has been a little bit of a guiding
light for me and I'm happy to have him
here in studio today so let's welcome
take Fletcher
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're live
hi Wow we're live man I'd like to walk
in live always but it always seems like
there needs to be a startup yeah you
know I mean like there needs to be an
intro know when you came in I mean I
wanted to be in I wanted to be in with
like the hood you know I just you know
bomber a little bit but then a little
bit I've been out see I watched
television recently I was a little sick
and so I was on the on the Netflix okay
do you not usually watch it
I'm not into I mean I'll go to sleep
with it sometimes but generally I'm not
not in that mode you know where
television is part of my daily [ __ ]
however I'm in it and then I saw this
thing rapture have you seen that uh-uh
it's got nas and jungle and Davey stand
now what are these I yeah and then
little starts off with that with that
kid logic and he's dope and so it's it's
a pretty cool little documentary type
piece and in TI's it talks about you
know going from kind of a trap rapper to
to kind of more social consciousness
kind of tip that he's on and I watched
him he was the second guy I saw that
wore sunglasses through a whole
interview he had these real nice D
design and I thought man and then I was
like cuz he always think that guy's a
[ __ ]
you know if he's got a sunglasses on
indoors yeah that's a certain type of
fella like yeah it seemed like somebody
I mean it's I mean the easy answers are
witness protection Italian what else
outside of that Oh sometimes senior
citizen where those might go Armenian to
a blue block oh yeah blue block absolute
locker and then you just forget it's
about Armenian like a devout Armenian
and if you're an old you got your
regular spectacles on and then you put
the blue blockers out you just maybe
forget when you walk in and get that
Twilight or something you don't know
yeah when you're old anyway you can wear
whatever I mean I remember club it's
kind of like a guy that might have an
Under Armour long-sleeve number on
compression gear and at the club oh yeah
that's too much same type of fella would
wear the glasses inside or until I said
like I said until I saw tee I do it then
I was like
well man maybe maybe you can do it maybe
I can do it
well it doesn't seem weird to me to have
you in it cuz you're like it's
disrespectful I don't see your eyes but
then I'm like you know I love you so
that gets okay but like if I were to
meet somebody else I'd be like hey how
you do you know right it's different I
think the thing is yet to me it doesn't
seem we're gonna go so now I think it's
weird now I'm just gonna wow don't let
me forget those though because it's so
Bravo side commenting what you said and
this is Tate Fletcher is here with us
today guys and uh and thanks so much for
coming in man yeah man I really
appreciate it it's good to be good stuff
and you know what I didn't think it was
weird that you had on sunglasses because
yeah like you said I trust you and I
know that you're okay person I guess if
I didn't know that or if I didn't think
that then I would maybe wonder what's
going on yeah you'd have a thought about
a fellow like that because you'd had is
he's not Italian right oh he's not yeah
and not Armenian no even though he is
friends with Sam Tripoli yeah whatever
yeah but that's just a quaint this is a
point in genealogy yeah that didn't get
you in the end the DNA like it's like
you know that you need it's qualify no
you're not rampant in my RNA structure
um now first I want to ask you about the
caveman coffee because I I just learned
it I just learned that you are one of
the proprietors of caveman coffee see
that right there I wear that CC on my
chest oh that's cool yeah I didn't
notice that I see that there's a
well-dressed felon and people yeah and
uh Nick is here Nick how are you I'm
doing really well thanks for coming
intake thank you you got the golden
black on which is a good strong look I
like that one I like that one and I
really like the black on black too but
it's my number one choice yeah
definitely I haven't shrunk this one I
wear out that black on black but the the
gold in the back this one makes a
statement
good yeah we got some new stuff too I'll
make sure that you guys get some yeah no
I'd love to have a came in coffee stuff
the first time I ever heard of it I was
when I went to Joe Rogan's podcast and I
I've heard he has and they had ha yeah
and they had it was like a little kind
of just like a fancy little can I guess
at maybe somebody with small hands would
use President of the United States a
little bit like a little people say it's
many people say it's Trump is Chris
Farley people say it's you
courses chris farley but I mean it's
like if Trump took a wrong turn that was
another thing I was watching there's a
Trump Trump you mentary
that's out I know really knew about the
early days oh wow all through the 70s
and 80s yeah yeah but that's probably
pretty interesting I'm trumped out I
mean just I'm just he loved that [ __ ]
all the time you bet back then he was he
was really an admirer of the vet
oh well Paulie sure I know talks about
being buddies with him and partying with
him you know and just like or just at
least chasing chicks I mean Trump
doesn't drink I know
can you imagine Paulie I mean that is a
vision a three-piece suit and then Pauly
Shore hang you know hit that like yes
the way was amazin the trike the the
Donald yeah that's a TV show if they
live together in a little house
somewhere I mean it could be a show one
day be at work yeah
I'd watch it so you had no idea I was a
part of the into tell you're guzzling
cans on Rogen yeah I didn't why I didn't
know this the first time I ever had it
and I was like oh this is exciting this
is like a soda little salt in your Peter
it's like a soda that's a coffee it made
me feel let me think it made me feel
like I was take it back if you got to
close your eyes and just let it wash
over you a little bit it may here's what
I made me feel like it made me feel a
little bit pensive because I didn't know
what a coffee like that could do to me
right right I've never had something
like that I might put a whack on you
you're not ready for like it's not the
one that you see coming that knocks you
and you're like I don't know exactly
what's in there that's dark water yeah
yeah yeah I don't want to see out it's
didn't want to be like so nervous I was
already nervous cuz I've never even
really talked to Joe Rogan so I didn't
want to be a thing in itself yeah wait
to that yeah and I think that you know
any famous person never appreciates that
you feel that way but they always they
know it that's a but [ __ ] that's god
that's a hard thing to wear yeah you
know I was like yeah I have so much
panache that you're like people are
uneasy but then also it's nice because
people act better
right there is a weird thing I met nelly
last night I saw ya I'm so excited dude
and he's healed up yeah yeah the
band-aids gone he's better so I don't
know what happened to him I guess it was
two melanomas and yeah it could have
been melon oh I don't know
um but I noticed though speaking about
like Fame and popularity I noticed like
I gave him a you know like he gave me
like a hug but I noticed I was talking
to him because I performed recently at a
casino that he performed at and I
noticed that he while I was saying that
he couldn't hear me saying it to him
like he was in that weird like famous
moment like where like he's ready for a
picture so he has to go through the
drill right he's done 40 million times
yes canon how many times has he done it
really like what's a number
I bet hundreds of thousands of pictures
that he's taken with yeah maybe 40,000
that's a lot 40,000 is a lot I mean how
many will like how many will Rogan do
after a comedy show maybe 20 or a
hundred oh if you wanted to stay in do
all my heart I heard I've seen him stay
for a long time oh I didn't know that I
mean I see people catch him in the hall
and they'll catch him and oh no but like
if you go see him in Texas or something
and then oh he may do so and he might do
500 oh yeah in that case yes it may be
that many and so Nellie it's like that
for decades for 20 years crazy yeah so
anyway but there was this thing he
couldn't hear me I know and it wasn't
that he was being rude or anything he
was he was giving me all his attention
but it was that it was like this famous
thing that I noticed famous people they
can't help where it's like you know
somebody's trying to express gratitude
towards you and like excitement about
you and you want to be gracious towards
them but you can't really hear them
because you're just you're almost going
through emotion like you know thank you
so much for being we get to the
supporter and then I'm gonna take more
time and then we're gonna say goodbye
thanks a lot thanks for your support and
then the next guy comes in and right
there's all that yeah yeah it's this
weird thing it's like um
have you have you experienced that on
the other side I mean of course you have
yeah I've experienced that over the
years like you know growing up you know
working on MTV and we got there was some
height of popularity there where you
know tons of people watch television and
and then now a little bit more with
comedy I've noticed and it happened more
but yet sometimes as this moment where
you it's hard to be present and gracious
a gracious act that you've done like a
bunch of times they're trying to be
present with you want to say a fan but
yeah but like a fan it's weird
it's not weird to think about that you
got fans I mean a little like it's like
it's weird but that's what they're here
because they admire something they saw
me do in a public setting right what
like it's a it's a trip man it's like
because you don't want to seem arrogant
right right it's like yes you do
anything not to see hair like humility
and admit that you have fans or whatever
it seems like it seems like your brain
goes all right liked it right quite
compute yeah yeah yeah it is weird and I
guess maybe like supporters teammates I
mean there's different kind of Terms of
Use but yeah it's tough it's tough too
um yeah it's tough because you you want
to get support and you want to garner
people that like what you do but you
don't want to seem you know you don't
want your ego to get infected infected
it is a weird thing and then there's
that little thing where this doesn't
feel it's like skipping school now we're
gonna skip school never gonna smoke
cigarettes yeah like all those O's as a
nine-year-old yeah or whatever and then
you don't skip school and then you you
know finally you know and whatever the
right circumstances come up and maybe
you skip school yeah sure is easy to
skip school the next day after you skip
it that first day you know but if you
don't skit like it's like there's a
block there and and so it's hard to like
temper the throttle I think as opposed
to just keeping the throttle off like
it's like abstinence in some ways is
like that's really the only way I'm
gonna keep this ship together is like I
can never skip school or else pretty
soon I'm just not a student anymore
right and I think it's like it's a thing
like like that like you've got a kind of
it's like there's always I don't know
that ego it's like this the only kind of
thing that has perpetual motion in this
world is our ego yeah and that grows all
by itself without any attention at all
and actually it the worst thing is is
the less you pay attention to it the
more its brought so like the more you
pay attention to it that's the place to
be but it's hard and it hurts your
emotions and it tears you up and then
you it breaks you down again and like
that thing about getting yourself I
think physically intellectually
emotionally spiritually all in in line
is that it's never there you've never
arrived
you've got to tweak those dials all the
time constantly and on that and and you
got to smash it like dude I'll tell you
I want I did this
I saw I love this number cuz I don't
know man it's great but an ego is one of
my biggest fears in life right now dude
thank you those converse yeah they're
commerson I just ordered a pair from
China right and then the website that
sent me a link Sandro's already pretty
cheap you got an order for an individual
I didn't mean to I just ordered the
first site that had them so then this
Chinese company sends me the shoes it's
not the shoes not good it's kind of like
a woman's rainbow wherever you are get
it together yeah and it's like and now
and but now they're asking me for the
money again I cancelled the payment and
now I feel bad cuz they're like we need
the money or my boss is gonna be upset
and now I'm like you want to know what
happened to me hmm
cuz [ __ ] them that's what I say [ __ ]
them I signed up at this cut you heard
of this place Equinox yeah listen I go
in there cuz I'm maybe gonna be a boozy
producer or something that's gonna make
me into Dwayne Johnson I can't even
stand to go in the place yeah I mean
cucumber waters not really my jam you
know I mean and so I'm in there for a
while and I fight the good fight and my
buddy Rico he goes to it out in Dallas
and so I figured it's an overall gym
that you can go to and that's where I'm
supposed to be right in some way like
the gym I work out at we're on cement
we're outdoors we got rocks and [ __ ]
like that that's where I that's my
wheelhouse
I mean so anyway I go to cancel there
and I'd cancelled in November and I sent
the email to the supervisor and to the
manager and and then they said well
you're gonna have to send a proof that
you have a bill from another place and
like I have a home business all that in
Santa Fe New Mexico and I was like well
I'm just traveling I'm on a job for work
I'll be gone on Waco for this next three
months and I can't I'm not paying for
this and I don't come here anyway so by
so we did all that and then just
yesterday I looked at my bills again and
I go honey still getting charged yeah so
then I call and I do the whole thing and
they go oh well we don't have that email
can you resend it I resent it and turns
out there was a letter wrong in an email
back to them and I was like that sucks
and she says listen I'm gonna come
halfway and I'm gonna give you half the
money back and it's like it's like two
yards a month man it's like 200 210
is expensive a fan so she's talking
about like 400 dollars instead of $800
or something like that she I was like
listen like I just got to say that this
is wrong like you're you're doing a
thing as a huge corporate endeavor to do
the wrong thing ethically like you're
choosing the wrong value system like
it's nothing to you to give a few
hundred dollars back to not leave a
horrific taste in my mouth right and
this just looks like your petty chintzy
mall [ __ ] right like you get that
right like and really I just want them
to know that they but that's like that
same thing and that's like if you're not
solvent in your [ __ ] and that's not like
let's have an equitable deal right if
it's not good for both sides it's not a
good deal and let's not do bad business
that already called bad business yeah
yes tell me equinox no look in Equinox
they said this man there that would wear
he wore headphones he had on a neck
first he had on he wore as much
accoutrements as you could get it and
perhaps rise accessorize fellows dude he
had the Horace Grant goggles remember
those the one like the first basketball
got like the Kurt Rambis and may and
maybe put a little sleeve on just up to
the elbow this so his forearm muscles
didn't wear out cramp up yeah yeah well
look but then he had on the thing he had
on a bandana and then he came out with
like this sport neck brace or something
like I guess he strained his neck which
I don't think he should be working out
after that no he had on the neck brace
and then he would jump rope in the
middle of yeah Thursday with a
children's jump rope that had like a
little like the pieces that separate you
know the red and white red and white the
children's oh in every day people would
video and just make fun of him and one
day finally the rope broke in the middle
and this all the piece it's like
confetti yeah and I ran up and grabbed
two of the [ __ ] pieces and put him on
a pocket right in front of him I never
said anything to him bright front brazen
just but I got that piece I needed that
but yeah man I wanted it I wanted to
think about that ego stuff you know
that's just my biggest huge deal it's an
infection the way it changes for me too
is like after you get good like
jiu-jitsu is great for that for a long
time but like after a while that you're
not terrified to do that and then it's
just it's uncomfortable it's important
to be that uncomfortable and have that
practice and to keep you there but like
to go deeper
it's another thing and like to expose
yourself right in all the ways it seems
like what we feel like we should protect
ourselves and really the the growth and
courage comes from exposing ourselves
everywhere do you have like moments in
your life where you feel like you've had
to do that kind of always yeah I've had
I mean you know you go from being like a
junkie to a sober person to a barista to
a professional athlete running a
business to like everything is like I'm
not the thing I was you know cuz all the
[ __ ] that I've done in my life has been
like I was this thing I completely
cannot be that thing anymore and so now
you're this thing so it's not even like
you're taking an old skillset and laying
it over it's like you need to be brand
new now and that's a scary place to be
and like you especially like quitting
fighting is a thing like that works like
guys will stay too long yeah because
it's scary to find out who would I be
without the adoration and the pride and
the all that stuff that having this
moniker affords me and so who am i
beneath all this and so do you remember
like some specific moments kind of that
cuz yeah I can imagine that I mean I can
imagine it's the same thing for you
you've been through it I mean even just
coming off TV and then going nah I
really am a comic I would this is what I
want you know and then it's like you
redrawn yourself yeah you know I mean
and I think that we we did our a
Gillette life that you can start to see
motor comes of success from that's one
of the skills is that you get agile at
being able to act with decisiveness to
become a new thing did you have to stop
being friends with someone you know to
go back to the fighting so because I do
want a little bit talk about you know
the wild shenanigans that have happened
with the with the fight you know
changing you know the new fighters this
week and people slipping in and out and
pretty crazy time pretty crazy but to
stay on what you were talking about yeah
so funny I was thinking about that
yesterday I was thinking about well I
wonder what that was like for Tait liked
you know to be involved in this I mean
did you see that that MMA and the
fighting itself was growing so much and
and did you feel like [ __ ] like I'm
getting off of a space shuttle like her
did you what was some of that are you
just
feel like it was a I mean it was a ride
that was like a regional ride that then
you know when like guys like me Diego
keith carradine
Carlos Condit like all those guys
started fighting that was we were
watching the UFC and pride and things
like that but like the SE G had own own
UFC at that time and then it was dark
for a couple of years and tell Zephyr
came and picked it up and so fights
worse their fighters were still fighting
fighters gonna fight yeah but um the
idea that we could be in the UFC or
something like seems so foreign you know
and then a bunch of dudes out of the gym
became champions and [ __ ] there it's
like and and it so is that first UFC is
like that was them throwing a Hail Mary
let's see if this will work and catch
fire yeah and then you know I was on the
third season of that and then then it
really start and then you're going yeah
you can see it's a meteoric rise but I
mean like Chuck Liddell used to [ __ ]
all the time he's like great I'm the
best guy of this thing that a bunch of
truck drivers like to watch you know
he's like and he's like so he just you
know was you know and but it's like that
thing that passing it's like now it's
like this mainstream thing and that's
the other thing that's why guys are
going you know I'd like to take swing at
this again you know you get BJ Penn want
to come back again you get Anderson
still in Italy odo these guys that could
have gone away as ghost stories like
Hicks and Gracie like just like
anomalies of nature like you know but
Chuck stayed a few fights longer than
that and like but it's easy to do
especially as the thing that you're
about to be disengaged from is taking
it's a [ __ ] it's hard that's I mean
that's a hard choice for a fellow to
make yeah was it a toy did was that so
is that like a you either choose to
leave or it chooses to leave you I mean
it's just like drinking you know if you
choose it and you can be proactive in
your removal yourself from that life hmm
it's way kinder on the body then if the
alcohol chooses when you leave you know
any kind of thing yeah and so the same
thing Fighting's the same kind of I
wouldn't call it an addition and a and B
but it's like it's like that kind of a
thing it's like if it chooses when you
leave that you're gonna be a lot worse
off for that and so
it takes a courage to get out in time to
think do you think you got out at the do
you think for you I mean obviously it
was the right choice
I'd aged out anyway had you I mean will
there be could there be a senior circuit
that would be hilarious and and so sad
that would be maybe the saddest circuit
they've talked about it I think but I
think it's pathetic come on I mean I
don't know to watch to watch like you
talk about watching Stephan Bonnar Chuck
Tito
like these guys that have already maybe
at what point are we gonna have
grandpa's too sooner or later as I call
it a master's class what's the best of
the best right
and then maybe let's watch a show with
those guys when they're not athletes
anymore because to be an athlete and
then to be a coach man that's hard but
like what about if they're just doing
that and like I'd rather see somebody's
passion going to something that make
sense instead of having a what becomes
kind of circus II yeah you know yeah no
that's true yeah maybe that's thinking
maybe it's too much Barnum & Bailey
you're mailing it in you know it's like
the fighter that's hungry to fight
that's a [ __ ] man
a guy that's got a hunger was there a
guy you got a real fighting because you
have to have food mm-hmm that's a
different thing altogether yeah and
that's what a master that's kind of what
you're talking about it's like so I'm
scared to go and become whatever god the
universe whatever has me become next and
so I'm gonna stay attached to my ego at
this thing which is the only thing I
know that ain't gangster yeah and when
the crazy part is a new throw you go in
there too it's like yeah it's hard to
know when you are being when you are
being resilient and staying in something
and being passionate right and when you
are beating a dead horse or if you're
beating a dead horse and no one really
it's hard to and if a friend tells you
are they a friend it's just that's such
a tough spot to be in well then as a
fighter if you bring up doubt so I've
infused doubt in you what are you doing
when you're done who if you start
thinking about that too much you're
gonna lose the day man yeah and you got
to be present the day to win and so like
that that becomes a conversation that
almost by necessity by design you must
push off mmm you know which is a tough
thing yeah you gotta have some ton of it
you almost have to have tunnel vision in
that sport yeah I got to work with a
friend of mine on a TV show on a movie
recently who's he's an active guy still
but he's been around for a long long
time and talking about that and he
starts bringing it up about like maybe
you know what he wants to do next and I
don't know he's he's uh real talented at
what he does but is there five fights is
there ten fights like and what does that
look like and what does it look like
because now you've you've got time that
you're taking away from when you start
the next thing mmm of what you are you
push that off five more years well would
it afford you a lot you know so you kind
of have to start doing a projected math
in your mind about like what all this
looks like and his name Damacio page
he's got a great like record he's got
he's a fantastic athlete but it's like
those guys that are still viable good
vibrant athletes like that it's like at
a certain point you go how much more
does my body take you know yeah one of
the guys that blows my mind it still is
like Diego Sanchez still in the game
since he was an Ultimate Fighter one man
why did he won that like that was his
right like and he was fighting I don't
know for years before that like like
it's so it's like that's a hell of a
career you know Josh Barnett you look at
these guys that have been around for
forever there's not a lot of them yeah
there's not a lot of guys that have been
doing it that long like and at that
point is that a loved you is it does it
transform from them believing do you
think you know or do you guesstimate
that it transforms from them believing
that they could still be the champion to
them believing that this is my life and
this is just what I do I think there's a
choice that guys make and they go I'm a
journeyman fighter that's gonna kind of
be the guy like that maybe holds the
line at the top 10 or that holds the
line for you know if the guys on his way
out like you're either a guy that's
fighting for the top or you're just a
guy that's in the space that's gonna be
a highlight reel for somebody on their
way there you know Wow and I think that
that's I mean that's the way I saw it
anyway and and I go you know at that
point it's like you look realistically
and you go okay is this something that I
can do here's guys that are the baddest
[ __ ] in my gym yeah am i as
good or better than those guys
and that's one question and then the
next question is are those guys viable
champions are they champions or are they
not and so that guy is or isn't he's not
even the champion and I'm not even close
to him what have I been doing here at
the party yeah you know it's like and
that can get in your head then so it's
like all these different things I mean
that guys behind the scenes of their
skull are dealing with all the time that
are ha and you know and and so a lot of
them look crazy and why does it look
crazy because I can't make it I can't
even have the question come up because
it's such a fragile question to ask my
mind it's like somebody put a hammer and
smashed ice and the whole psyche started
to fracture then because of this
question so I cannot allow the question
right oh yeah I'm the [ __ ] bass dude
and like a lot of guys it's like people
are and then all the fans will say well
this disguise better because this thing
no but you're not understanding cuz you
never [ __ ] put nothing on the line
fanboy yeah that like he's all-in man
cuz that's who he must be right you know
you have to be a bit deluded a bit crazy
you know I can't imagine I can't I don't
know if I've ever because when I think
about fighting for me I'm not a fighter
look I got beat up a couple times I was
good at [ __ ] laying on my back and
kicking at people that were trying to
punch me you had a good ground game yeah
you're saying I mean I got yeah I mean I
don't know I just you know what I was
just super scared you know it's more of
a of a talk or a thing but so I think
then fighting is like I even have dreams
and I don't know if you've heard of this
I'll have a dream where I'm throwing a
punch in a dream and it doesn't it stops
like halfway and it won't my arm won't
even go any further matter how hard I
push it's like you're throwing through a
marshmallow or something looks like slow
motion like no yes no power but like all
this rage and anger I can feel but my
body won't let me it's crazy yeah and I
don't know what that means I just think
I just mean do not fight you know I'm
not good I think maybe it could be an
unexpressed energy that you're needing
to get out and the way that you can get
that out and that you can train at full
speed that is at the top efficacy of the
sport is Brazilian Jiu Jitsu really and
I think that that's the thing that males
like need
get out to address like there's there's
parts of ourselves that we don't
confront routinely yeah I think that
some of us get comfortable not
confronting them but like when we do
great things happen you know don't know
what some of that man let me tell you
this I was at UH I want to let the fans
are too I I do forget sorry you were a
Don I mean but we do if you want to get
because I'll do you want to support you
I wanna support caveman coffee we have a
code oh yeah yeah I'm not trying it off
with an air but it's Theo if you co
fused Theo at caveman coffee calm and
you can see it on Instagram story on
caveman or on tape flutter on mine Theo
is the code and I put it on there too I
put it on mine as well but anyway yeah
you guys can get a discount there so I
just want to remind all that and I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go where are you
gonna go I'm gonna make a purchase as
well I'm gonna go away yeah imma get
Nick a new black % off and that's a
caveman coffee koat.com caveman coffee
cocom 15% off
OHE Oh we'll get some of we'll keep some
here in the in studio is it weird to
have a longer first name than last name
was there another thing after the Vaughn
did you cut it off oh yeah ops I did I
donated a lot of letters to Vaughn
Felder something or Vaughn rothenstein
or von Kahr natal ski full last name so
you were Admiral no I wasn't I was uh
I'm polish Nicaraguan ah [ __ ] yeah
pretty much I'm guessing cuz that's not
a land maybe you know what though that's
sexy yeah I mean really you know I mean
yeah good you know I think well I was
trying to get more back into my Latino
culture and try to you know trying to
take more Spanish father taught me
someone oh it seems odd for a fellow
looking at you the way you look like a
beautiful blond haired boy with green
eyes and pale skin like to talk about
your Latin roots yeah this falls on me
ah
yeah well the crazy thing is in my town
growing up I had like my brother and I
had like the darkest skin around you
know outside of black kids and people
would always call us picks and like
racial slurs oh you were the closest
thing to black that wasn't black yeah
people were like you [ __ ] just write
your idiot you know I mean they would
call you racial name oh yeah you [ __ ]
like what good we don't even know what
we are leave us alone I had no idea I
was oblivious to that [ __ ] yeah we had
Mexican kids they'd be the Ortega's
around I just thought they were white I
was like I had no idea like you're
growing up I was like the same [ __ ] yeah
I wish we'd had more diversity and I
think now it's getting you know you're
seeing more diversity in a lot of places
but it would've helped us out a lot
growing up just for people to get to
have a better idea of what other people
are like you know I wish we'd ahead
probably we had we didn't have any we
just didn't have a lot of it that's why
black panther struck me is so important
yeah it was like I've never really
dawned on me until I've been having a
lot of talk with feminists and lately
yeah been in raging and enlightening
it's amazing they're like when you go
okay I just want to hear like how come
maybe you think whatever and and one
thing that the I was enlightened to was
the fact that any images like if you go
in the courthouse or you see statues or
you look at the money we have there's no
women or people of color on any of those
things yeah you know what I mean there's
none there's just white dudes yeah and
so if you look at all that and you're a
little kid and you're not a white dude
it's got to read a certain way and that
just that I was like okay and then I
watch Black Panther and I go holy [ __ ]
cuz when I grew up as a little kid there
was a great show on called roots mmm-hmm
and when I say great I mean it was like
a [ __ ] horror movie that was a
miniseries that went on for like eight
weeks or something it was and you're one
of the people most watch television
shows ever beaten you're watching slaves
feet cut off you're seeing the rapes in
front of parents and children you're
seeing this the demoralisation of a
whole humanity like you're just watching
the most atrocious events happen to
black people and if you're a black kid
watching the hojae Simpson was in it was
he I had no idea if you're a black kid
you watch that you go that's available
to me that's my skin and that's what
people can do to people like I never
yeah I I've never really dawned on me
like that is a camera girl and then I go
okay you grow you you're born in 2000
and you grew up in you see black panther
and you go wow some people are good some
people are bad but like I'm from Kings I
could be a superhero and that's that's
some different [ __ ] man that's a
different consciousness from the gate
it's like so we marginalized people with
subliminal [ __ ] that like and I would
just was never present to that before I
go oh my god I'm it's like I woke up a
little bit you know yeah it's funny you
say that I've had some of that same
experience recently I was thinking about
because when I was young the only
wealthy black people were people on
coming to America the movie and people
and the Dallas Cowboys those are the
only as far as I knew you know they had
a great deal of black people to mock
though right yeah but they had a great
deal of I feel my town but they didn't
there just wasn't the opportunity for
them to have wealth you know it just and
I didn't realize it as much when I was a
kid I mean you know I thought a lot of
us are poor but I didn't i didn't see
that their opportunity wasn't exactly
the same until I got older and now I see
oh it's like well yeah if generation
after generation you know your
great-grandfather getting a parking
ticket means you might not go to college
right you know then that is not that is
a very or get born because out of that
traffic ticket he maybe gets beaten to
death
yeah or whatever I mean it's like yeah
if you're if you look at it as a kid and
you go yeah I didn't see the difference
because the opportunity we're all on the
same bucket but then when you realize I
can get out of the bucket and people
aren't treating me different like it's
like right and this guy can't get out of
that bucket that there's that's a
barrier to entry that's not available to
him I mean yeah a black friend of mine
recently uh this guy Jeremy Scipio
comedian I was working with this boy
yeah yeah it does sound very Italian and
actually as kind of as Italian pasta
alysha's Sicilian I could see him being
an Italian
in very well done blackface actually but
um this guy Jeremy Scipio he was saying
well let me think about it with you like
this he said as a black man I have to
[ __ ] with white people to make money in
America he goes as a white man you don't
have to [ __ ] with black people to money
and it was just an interesting you know
and I'm not saying that's true in every
instance or you know but it was
interesting to Facebook that I know as a
prostitute yeah and she wrote on her
Facebook I will not work for a man ever
as if she was reading I won't chew gum
in class like over and over again on her
Facebook post that was it and I thought
wow she's really stepping up for one and
then I thought you're you're literally
your job is that you're gonna men will
pay you like that's what you do right
people confuse Theo that's all I'm
saying
oh is it ton of confusion out there but
to go back to a little bit what you're
saying of what I was hearing I remember
I remember thinking recently when I was
young if you saw a Walt Disney go to
Disney World or Disneyland commercial
and all the people and there were white
that is a black kid if you saw that it
made me think man that must have been
even if they if even if they didn't
recognize it at the time there must have
been kind of painful to watch you know
or later were to look back at and be
like Oh Disney World like I mean they're
not saying I'm not welcome but they're
it's there's probably a feeling there
you would get that I'm not and that puts
that puts some things into context a
little bit more for me also any grocery
store yeah or any I mean everywhere it's
it's [ __ ] different then and then you
but then you also have like on the grant
like I remember like they were removing
a lot of the statues in New Orleans and
I had gone and met at those statues the
robert e lee statue with black and white
kids every year for mardi gras and no
one gave a [ __ ] no one ever gave a [ __ ]
and so it's some things I'm like you
know we can't it does it rearranged is
there but let's educate everybody about
what the [ __ ] you know let's get hip
to the skip maybe we put an additional
plaque next to each one yeah and go hear
some here's some other things about this
also like it's not all cuz it ain't all
gravy or put another statue next to it
of some you know someone that's we're a
part of the days we're past the days
where people had to be impeccable yeah
in their behaviors and all that I mean
we've got Weiner
we got senators sending full dick pics
out to all of Twitterverse everybody we
drop everybody everybody's crazy
everybody's so we're able to see that
people aren't infallible yeah well you
know we're able to see yeah [ __ ] bilge
it he loved a [ __ ] at the White House
there or like there's all these things
that we see about each other where we're
able to give each other enough learning
room enough rope that if you don't go
the marks too much you'll be able to
learn still you'll still be able to
evolve like cuz we're all in this
unfolding this becoming and then that's
what I worry about these conversations
are like to control the space for that
is almost dangerous because now you're
censoring a natural evolution of these
conversations to come out and go let's
have the full conversation it is so
let's not undo it it's like saying that
weeds illegal or something that's like
after it's legal it cannot be unlike you
cannot Unknowing right right and so we
can't unknow history and it's also
routinely and historically dangerous if
we do so yeah yeah it's uh I mean
wrongheaded with the right the right
heart going the wrong direction I feel
like yeah there's a we are at a really
interesting time where we're calling
into account where we are I feel like we
are taking a little bit of an inventory
of who we are as a country yeah you know
it's a little bit like a roll call yeah
and I think in some ways it's happening
you know I even think some of you know
like I mean I know there's a lot of
stuff like border control and stuff like
that but it's like we almost do need to
know who's in a let's see who who we are
so we can you know just so we can kind
of and go everybody good with it
everybody good with it and the people
they're like no no dude except for the
Syrians we're not good with it we go
okay cool we got everybody agree with
him and then we get those people away
yeah and we take a really I mean it's
like the thing is is like the beauty of
us is that we're all fresh the beauty of
10th planet jiu-jitsu like that Eddie
Bravo started is that it accepts all
things that have efficacy yeah it's not
so much into the ideology that like hey
dude if this works we don't want it
because it came from them or so it's
like no let's take all the stuff and
make the best [ __ ] make that [ __ ] that's
how that's called evolution yeah yeah
and it's a I think we're gonna need in
human evolution I think it's scary look
it's tough mean there are daily moments
where I have to let go of some of my own
thoughts and ideas and adapt some new
ones so and that goes back to the
destroying the ego for me it goes back
to like yeah we need to confront all
these things and it's an inside job I'm
the fish I got a catch and so how do I
know that I'm doing
the right things cuz I'm terrified what
I'm scared to death I know that I'm
probably on the right path should
[ __ ] courage up and go through that
thing Wow
and so that's the things that I think
that you go to address the ego - how do
I crush it daily I do that [ __ ] that's
scary I do that uncomfortable thing I do
that thing that's out of the way of my
comfort you know it's funny I mean yeah
I was just like you know I deal with
like dating and like any messy issues I
was talking Jay Mohr and I had a big
conversation about this last weekend
now do you date like a individual
girlfriend or you like to just like I'm
a date different gave dates with some
girl for a little bit now you know and
so but one of my big issues is when it
comes to like somebody that I care about
us
intimacy stuff and there's moments where
it's like I'll know that like the last
all I want to do right now is just be by
myself but I can tell somewhere inside
of me that I need to not be that way I
need to like go into the thing because
you're afraid of isolated yeah no
because I'm afraid of not expressing
some show of care or concern right so
but instead of do it like my brain my
heart the way I'm something inside of me
my ego whatever it is it's damaged
inside of me be like nah you know just
turn your shoulder and just you know
make a smoothie or go in the other room
and do but then there's that part of me
that's like the scariest thing for you
to do right now would be to like go and
like give that girl a kiss or something
just to say you know look you know I
know things are tough or something like
that like something that but it makes
you [ __ ] feel like you got a swallow
vomit in your throat yeah say it yeah
and you're like why is saying that I
know I love you and I support you so
hard right now yes
that's being supportive like that's the
biggest thing almost is just even being
supportive that thing of like why is it
at certain times I get my emotion so
bottled up that it feels like I'm gonna
throw up in my own mouth say that I care
about like and it's like that's the time
to do it I made a dude by a dude flowers
one time because he did the wrong [ __ ]
man and he almost beat this dude up at a
at this recovery function where all
these people are just fresh and trying
to have a bright new life and all that
and like and he had a pool party at his
house and and he said you know this dude
so stole my mom's watch you know and
which is shitty right yeah and he he
might have grabbed him might have
slapped him whatever something like some
public shaming around peers and and then
found out that his mom took the what
that wasn't a thing and and I go dude
you got to make it right somehow he goes
I don't know how to do that and I go I
feel like you need a public it has to be
public it's got to be in front of the
same people you got to go to all those
people and like and so then he did
another thing in here and I said you got
to buy him flowers yeah I ain't buying a
dude flowers I'm like at what point are
you gonna give up at what point is this
gonna be the trippin thing that makes
you have cancer later like and and he
and his credit got on board bottom
flight but it's like that thing that you
really that's usually the thing you
wanted I was there to [ __ ] audition
not an audition I took one of these
acting classes I'm in an acting class
right no I know it look I and we haven't
gotten into a bunch of your career and
stuff you know but I know don't need to
but I want would the point that I like
is that I gotta go on I got to do this
monologue for as opener in this class I
never done a monologue before I've done
a lot of auditions I got like and so I'm
there and I go well before I go and I go
am I gonna go first they lock the door
at 2:30 so again hey lock they're
serious no I don't want serious I want
to hands off a little bit a little bit
laissez-faire for me thank you but
they're not playing that way so I go am
I gonna go first just bust a nut and get
it done or what because there's like
eight other people that have to deliver
the monologue we're gonna be here for
hours today and I go and then a guy goes
I'll go for it and I was like I guess
that's how he's doing it he does a
cláudio from Shakespeare
yeah and Hamlet and and he was a guest
any any blows blows through it and then
I find out that he's done this twice as
employed actor in theater and plays he's
played Claudio so he took it easy so he
knows it I just got this thing Sam Bick
assassins from a week ago I never heard
of the play before I don't know [ __ ]
about this and so that's where I'm
learning it from I was like what god
that guy he really had a cheek oh I
would have so then I see the rest of my
go I'll go last
yeah cuz maybe I'll run out of time
maybe I won't have to go at all cuz
that's how my mind works and then I hear
him and I go God there they're all good
oh they're all really good and I go now
I hate this feeling go I can't go I like
I go maybe I should just leave right now
I said clearly I'm in the wrong class
because these guys are really good and
I'm I'm not even off-book
I'm ashamed mmm maybe yeah maybe I'll
fake an injury on the way up to the
stage and I'll just pull a hammy and I'm
like you're seated bro like that not
believable yeah and then it's like you
can't pull off a monologue but now
you're planning to pull off so so then I
go up and I'm and it's the last thing
and whatever and I go and and it's
horrible and it's all that tear off and
anyway the thing is is going you know
today we have that experience and all
the outrageous ridiculous things that
your head contrives for you to worry
about you're not getting kicked out
nobody's gonna laugh at you everybody's
here to learn this is what you're here
for what the [ __ ] is wrong with like all
the thing it doesn't make any sense I
get but the growth afterwards of walking
through the thing like I felt myself pop
in my car later I'm like I'm different
than I was yes and I used to get that
feeling from jujitsu and [ __ ] like it
but so that's the thing as I go where's
an engagement that I can get in life
where I can do this continually where I
can confront myself just to be able to
be a normal dude that I can tolerate and
not have to kill and you find that in
jiu-jitsu and I find that what you just
I find that whatever that is I think you
can do it with like if you go to get
great if you endeavor to be great at
something and then you get in a little
bit and then you get in really deep and
you see how deep the water is and after
you know enough to know that you know a
lot and it's easy and then you know a
little bit more to know that you don't
know [ __ ] and you're in those waters now
that's the important water we got to get
out over the reef to get out those
waters you know you got it you got a try
you got to intend to suffer you have to
have intentional suffering mmm and then
you get freedom in the rest of your life
and now when you left fighting was there
was there some of that with some of your
next endeavors like what was was there
something you tried that didn't pan out
everything dude everything's a failure
in my life like I'm not a fan of any of
my [ __ ] like I just everything I just
see where it could have been better
different whatever and I feel like with
wherever that goes if you start a
business I don't care if you start a
t-shirt company or something like
whatever it is you're doing
it's like there's so much to learn if
it's to be a sustainable thing and now
my thing is like I've got a few things
popping and I'm like okay so you breathe
life into these things who are you if
you're not a good steward of those
things and they turn to dust like you're
your son of a [ __ ] men like you've got
to be responsive like and that's part of
the thing it's just maturing of going
I've got a responsibility to this thing
I've created now and I want to be a good
steward of it it's like the first time I
got any money man I go I I want to find
guys right away that knew how to deal
with money because well that's because I
go I want to be a good steward of this
thing if I don't care for this energy
everybody says they care about [ __ ] you
know I'll watch a guy and be like yeah I
care about this gym I care about it I
care about and he works for the dude
that owns a gym and I see that same dude
walk by a [ __ ] Kleenex on the floor
four or five times an afternoon I'm like
you don't care care is you're taking
you're wiping the leaves off the plant
you're watering it you don't just say I
care about that plant and a your hands
off yeah you're in it man I can see
you're care and I can and that's the
thing to get to with these things I
think is to really endeavor to show that
you know you you're a steward of this
energy yeah who cared about you you
think most in your life do you feel like
cared about me or my mother yeah yeah
I'm sure
yeah is your mother alive yeah she lives
in Santa Fe oh that's beautiful area
that's why she's the reason I cut my
beard off last year oh really
yeah oh that was such a big crazy tell
she was asking along for four years and
and I'd always been working and then I
never could and then she came out and we
were gonna go to see Rahm Das and jack
Kornfield and all these spiritual
healers she'd been admiring for a long
time in Maui at this seminar she came
out here a couple days first and then
she went Laci took her off to have
dinner and then I went over to Logan's
house and I just shaved all my beard off
and then once our and just look on her
face is worth all of it but and why what
was that she's just cry mean she'd never
seen my face and so she's right looking
at expressions and [ __ ] she hadn't seen
I never thought about it but it is it's
like you're robbing a train you have a
bandana around your face the whole time
haven't
it's kind of that way especially that
[ __ ] was just crazy on me and and so
she's like looking at her little boy
again I think it was something like that
like like a bunch of spent yeah cuz
there's probably yeah things elements
and you know angles and stuff in her
brain and you know and some of the best
memories that she you didn't even
realize not purposely but she doesn't
get to see right and then she got to see
him all at once yeah yeah I bet a moment
like that really lets you know how much
she cares I mean just even almost
intangibly well all of it man I feel
like a like that that's one of the I
guess big guiding things I feel a
responsibility to her to you know like
you know I was like why not kill
yourself because your mom's still alive
you know right it's like it's like a
really there's days in it and it gets
like that you know yeah I mean I
remember burying one of my best friends
you got killed by the police when we
were kids and well we weren't kids were
I guess in her 20s but um but and his
mom and standing by his casket and
looking at him and and her bawling and
she squeezes my hand and she says Tate
you got a stop man she says you're not
supposed to bury your kids I'm not
supposed to bury my son's men and and
it's daunting you know like things like
that and you go there's a higher
responsibility here whether it's to
supernatural beings or whether the beans
right here but but it's everywhere man
and and I feel like I tried to shirk my
responsibility as a human for a lot of
years and I felt like I didn't ask to be
responsible I didn't want to be didn't
want to be born thanks and then you go
this is what is and if I want to live
any kind of a spiritual life I have to
accept what is and then I have to be
responsible with that thing and with
with the energies that I create I mean
that becomes a calling and I think I
think even like it's like with with art
or with whatever it's like there's a
responsibility if if you're to enjoy the
fruit that your art gives you there's a
responsibility for you to throw your art
away routinely and you create new art
mmm otherwise I mean it's like you know
you're [ __ ] 60 doing nursery rhymes
or you're doing you're doing things that
are like that are yesterday's news and
that's what I really admire about all
the comics that I see especially is that
like I watched Ripley's deal the other
week
yeah and I'm hearing material that I've
ten years you know they he'll never do
again yeah because now it's memorialized
he's been a good steward of it put a box
and a bow on it tied it up it's off and
now into the new things and watching
Rogan do that continually every year for
the last 15 years I've been friends with
him and watching Ari Shaffir do that and
what it's like I get to see what success
looks like when I'm around other people
that have a real high regard for what
excellence of their craft is mmm and and
I think that me surrounded myself in
those circles I mean I feel privileged
to be able to and then also it's what I
demand it's like if if you don't have
that kind of a consciousness I probably
don't [ __ ] with you not that I don't
love you yeah but there's only so much
time and and I got to be careful my
energy and and and that's affected by my
surroundings and by the biology around
me ya know I love this man I love I mean
I you know I'm you're some letter I
can't get over oh thanks man I just I'm
sorry I haven't mentioned it yet and I
just keep yeah it's good did I chair the
meeting today in this really yeah what's
up Fillion which was why really and I
didn't meet I just didn't want this is
black at a perfect time of the year for
Adam everything I just wanted something
that was not contrary that would
contrast with these black chairs yeah um
I'm gonna know better next time I get
invited back I'm gonna dress better for
short no please come back man I know I
love hearing what you're saying because
these are the things it's so crazy that
I just feel like I need to hear my life
right now you know like even just
personally you know I need to hear that
you know about letting go and about
surrounding yourself you know with
people that you can keep you in a better
place in your conscious in a better
place and people that you admire stuff
that they do even if it's outside of
your comfort ability zone because it's
like you said there's only so much time
and it's like man if I if I wattle
around some here with some people or
some people are bringing me down or some
people that aren't are just taking from
me and that don't you know don't that
aren't not helping in a greedy way but
there aren't just meeting me halfway I
need to be interested yeah you know it's
how I feel are making me halfway
at least you
you know if I only got room for these
people around my life like my picket
fence I call it right and there's there
and it's good to have a person that's
super advanced in one hand and somebody
new on the other hand right that's a
good balance to have man that's a
conduit of strength right there that
happens but the thing is is for that
close close circle if there's somebody
that doesn't really contribute with
positive energies and in whatever way
that is and they're just kind of there I
have to understand that I'm making a
choice to not be as good as I could be
because this could be a spot that
somebody that super vibrant and into
this whole vibe and as a contributor
could be in which would enhance it and
so am i doing everybody else in my
circles a service by continuing to [ __ ]
with somebody that's like nah man good
enough good enough for me and I'm just
mail it in that's cool man but that's
not energy I can have because I want to
start mailing it in I'd like to retire
into nothing and be a lazy fat shooting
dope on the couch [ __ ] yeah in
the park but I cannot afford to man I
cannot afford it and it looks maybe
meaner or more cutthroat than it is but
it's like my very life at stake in a way
it's like if there's not progression and
it's like I'm not chasing wealth and not
that I don't want all that but it's like
that's not what my progression is my
progression is so I don't kill myself my
progression is so that I don't become so
nihilistic to drink in a bottle of
bourbon and sitting on the side of the
road is just as good is driving a
hundred thousand dollar car and being in
a loft and being able to be
inspirational helpful to a bunch of
different people all around me yeah it's
the same thing to me at a certain point
right and so if I don't have people that
are [ __ ] in engendering my health and
my vibrance towards a greater life it's
it's not about the [ __ ] trappings man
it's about my souls at stake
yeah it's about you and I just got here
to be a good son the only one I got to
be clear about that what this me right
and yeah and I'm why am i protecting
myself cuz my mom's still alive yeah
but yeah responsible you yeah there's
certain point you have responsibilities
and it's almost scary to think that you
do if you think about some of your
emotional responsibilities or if you
take them on like that you know to be a
son to be a brother even to be a friend
I was talking to a friend earlier
to be a friend and I was like you know
you get hypoglycemic you turn into a not
as a nice person and all the time it's
like people have to remind you have you
eaten today and it's like if you're not
doing the basic [ __ ] to take care of
yourself
I just can't [ __ ] with you man yeah I'm
sorry we're at such a different place if
we're troubleshooting to get better all
the time and you're troubleshooting like
how to step around a mud puddle still
good luck man but you need to be around
other mud puddle steppers right you know
I mean I'm over here trying to do some
consciousness shifting [ __ ] right yeah
and that and that's just how it is man
and it's like not everybody can help
everybody you know some people are too
far down the road to be able to do this
or that or whatever I don't know I don't
know what it is but I know it's
something I need to be careful of I
don't have it all worked out yet I've
been writing it I'm trying to write a
book I can see that I love listening to
you man and I would read and I would
read you but I think what you said a
second ago is having somebody who youth
you see as like a lighthouse in one hand
and somebody you see as somebody you can
help in some way of service yes in
another yeah because then that chain of
that chain of hands goes further down
and so then somebody's holding on to the
mud puddle step right that's just maybe
you're not in that part of the chain
that's a good way to look at it yeah you
know man I love it's not my most it's
not that I'm washing myself a
responsibility here right but that can
happen with a trick like if as long as
I'm looking to advance here like if I if
I don't look to make me the best
representation to take Fletcher that I
could be walking through the world today
yeah then anybody I would help is
diminished also it's like that it
becomes like that anyway you know your
highest good has to be to you ya know
why is that so I can be useful to others
yeah that's it
yeah you said the word conjured a little
bit ago and I think more and more like
that as more I take care of myself
the more I find that I can be a conduit
from some higher power or something to
do things that help others that make me
then feel good yeah you know and and I
like you purposeful yes right yeah a lot
of it but like but you write well like
like [ __ ] you know is that I remember
the first time I dude remember my name
for me like a lot of people I don't know
how I could be helpful this or that and
I I was a new into LA and uh I wouldn't
be tearing up a little bit I just yeah
man I think so much about how much being
purposeful is just it's becoming I think
the thing it's it listen like where the
where this guy is helpful to me I came
back the next week to the same place and
it was like Tate how are you doing he's
got no [ __ ] reason to remember my
name yeah but I'm mad and it was the
first time I go I mattered like it felt
and you can make somebody feel like they
matter if you just [ __ ] get out of
yourself enough to remember their
[ __ ] name tell the next time you see
them yeah and it's like it becomes that
thing and this friend that you know
there's a lot of people in America it's
weird because we have more tense than
ever I've never seen I don't know if
tense just became popular if people are
just really calling it camping instead
of homelessness and yeah but like right
on sunset like in downtown areas where
we never had it before I'm Beverly
Boulevard and La Cienega
there's tent set up last night and I was
like this is a [ __ ] this is crazy you
know and and with all that going on in
America and we got a president saying
we're winning like crate and and people
in the middle are like life's always
hard here it's always kind of been sucky
and it still is it's there's no people
with tents there cuz people don't want
to live in Indiana or whatever the [ __ ]
it is yeah and and so they don't feel
that but that's like here on the fringes
man we're falling apart a little bit and
and and but the bottom line is
regardless is I've got a friend that's
got the what I would call the disease of
affluence and and what happens is I used
to work in these nightclubs and I'd see
all these really rich kids and they grow
up with no consequences and and it's
dangerous man and it and it looks shitty
to all of us viewing it but really it
with any empathy it's worse for them and
they start to believe all kinds of lies
and things that when that veil is
removed from them that safety not holy
it's that's a dark dark area but with
that I have a friend that is like grew
up in a real advantageous environment
yeah you know and and is like really
Dell
into spirituality and trying to figure
out herself and all that kind of stuff
and feels ashamed of it mmm because
doesn't have the same concerns about
having to find a career this or that or
whatever that a lot of people do or is
and isn't drawn to like having a baby
and that whatever all the thing that
people do to avoid themselves right yeah
no not my purpose is my kid cuz I was
too scared to confront my own life and I
don't know how to live it so I [ __ ] out
a kid and I'm gonna show them out and
not do [ __ ] - yeah so if she's making
some real courageous choices is my point
but like what is Oprah do what does
Leonard Cohen do what does everybody do
as soon as they get papered up man they
try to find God they try to make sense
of it all with spirituality like
everybody looks towards those common
universal vibrations that echo through
all of our hearts and souls and connect
us all that's that we're trying to
curate that vibe of the universe man
that's what everybody tries to do and so
at whatever point you're trying to do
that that's that's the right end game I
think yeah and so when you say it's
turning more into this consciousness I'm
like I feel like that that's that's the
right place for us to go yeah and there
will be a schism there will be a divide
you know yeah yeah III I mean I think
we're on a lot of elements everywhere I
think there's a lot of things where I
didn't think it for a little bit but now
the more I find myself being around that
kind of stuff the more I start to
believe that that is the truth
which is interesting - you speak it in I
mean you can you speak the truth into
existence you know and I see it I mean
the more I put myself in environment
where I see people being helpful to
other people and stuff like that the
more I start to believe that that's the
answer that I never really saw for some
reason before you know when all you
really got to do is sit with somebody
that you really helped that you've
impacted and the feeling that overwhelms
me is that there's there's never such a
resounding feeling that I'm in correct
placement in the universe right in the
palm of the hand of God at that very
moment and I'm comforted in a way that I
never am when I'm deep into service like
that yeah there's nothing that is like
that there just isn't and we look for it
a lot of other places that aren't the
place yeah yeah man it's the Easter egg
hunt man chocolate rabbits in our hearts
dude yeah you know yeah we talked about
the fight but real quick I want to talk
about just you talked about Brazil you
know a certain time on your podcast no
we can go over long but I know what's
your general timeframe an hour two hours
hour and a half yeah I don't know how
long we've been talking an hour I'll
spend about an hour and yeah usually
about 90 minutes seems like yeah you're
only the second guess we've ever had no
way yeah really so we had Jay Mohr last
week and then you yeah we just got him
to the new studio and um so it's been
awesome man and nick has been so helpful
and uh oh and Chris Perez has been so
helpful he's not here nick has to train
him so we can have her I was wondering
cuz it's interesting to have like just
like a I really like just conversational
podcasts and then like the way that job
does his where he's very regimented and
pretty rigid in like like he's making a
real show like a finely designed show
you know which I'm like you're like an
adult you know but he's like the most
adult though to anybody that I've seen
going I can it is everyone's got these
different packs that they're taken and
some people to know we got to keep it
under underneath an hour because
attention spans then I was on Rogen once
and we only went for an hour because we
both had to blast and that's the only
thing people complained about that it's
only an hour and I'm like there's no
rules here yeah so it's just interesting
to see all the choices that we all make
inside the space you know yeah I think
we're still learning you know I think um
yeah we're still learning like I was so
nervous to put out the interview with
Jay Mohr know why I think just I don't
know I just get nervous about I guess
part of it is that a lack of some parts
of self confidence and then that I don't
want to something always got me that I
don't want to waste people's time yeah I
hear that there's this big thing and
I've always felt that another way I
don't want to waste people's time I get
that because I don't know if maybe I
always felt growing up that like man
it's crazy I never even thought about
this before but that's somehow that I
was a waste of that I was a waste of
people's time maybe somewhere I got this
weird thing inside of me that made me
feel like I was a waste of people's time
maybe I don't get
attention or something and so then I
felt that way that's how I you know I
was like oh well if I'm not getting the
attention I need it's because I'm a
waste of time right you know maybe I
know you're not of a conference on on
your people or something there like a
another task that they have to yes take
care of yeah yeah so I never even really
turned it like that a little bit um but
I want to know how can Brazilian Jujitsu
help a guy help what ways can we see
that something like that can help people
outside of the physical element ways
that they never thought of like what are
other things you kind of touched on it a
little bit ago I think a lot of it can
happen with almost anything it's like
it's like coming here it's like to go to
what you're saying it's like I'm nervous
coming here to be on a podcast with you
which is in essence I'm nervous to come
and have a conversation with my friend
that I really admire like how weird is
that that doesn't come up why is your
ego talking to that wait 8 right you
know but then I come and I show up and
then I and then whatever happens happens
and then you know I'm not nervous now
about putting a note cuz [ __ ] it I feel
like a jackass anyway
might as well just expose it put it out
it is what it is and I just go and I
throw it all away after it but it's
always before for me that it's
bothersome but it's like that way to
drive to a gym to an acting class to
jiu-jitsu class to a wherever you're
going whatever it is you're undertaking
that is a takes some modicum of
discipline if you're Weight Watchers
meeting whatever it is if you go there
regardless of how you feel about it it's
better almost if you feel like there's
no way I can go I don't have time I hate
this that's even better and you go
anyway if you just it's so part of it
was like training contrary action I
would go anyway and then I avail myself
to the process and then I walk out a
different man and it happens every
single every single time and so and
that's just what happens with the gross
construct of going in coming out right
okay yeah right
and then in jujitsu man I get the
problem solved life I get to forecast
life I get to look down the road I get
to troubleshoot what
mal-intent are going on I get to I get
to create subterfuge if I want I get to
manipulate a little bit and all in a
language that only you and I are
speaking to each other and nobody else
is really listening and even people that
are watching that could that could
listen that know the language they're
not seeing everything because there's so
much pressure and counter-pressure and
and different points that are that they
can't know that either that only you and
I that our community and it's like so
you're having these convert its a
[ __ ] conversation that's going on
jiu-jitsu teaches you a language with
which to trouble and then after you and
I are finished with others they'll come
we go to help each other to clean up our
[ __ ] so that we'll both have a harder
time with each other next time it really
doesn't make sense if you're looking at
a competition based lifestyle
mmm-hmm but what Darwin wrote about in
origin species was not competition
solely his intent was to talk about how
we are born of cooperation and and and
through when we butt up against each
other
we cooperate ourselves into a tighter
knit better more efficient version than
we were previously Wow
so tribal you know and and that's what
happens and jiu-jitsu all the time and
the thing is is if I don't if I just
want to get if I just want to be the
best if I want to you know solve my ego
then I just keep killing you same
triangle choke every time I kill you the
same thing you're like this guy's got a
great triangle it's like nope you just
suck and don't know my trick right and I
get to stay there forever as the boss
but if I show you my setups and I go hey
here's what's happening dude and what I
do don't let me do this dude you let me
do this every time don't let me do this
and I teach you how to avoid my triangle
now we both get exponentially better
yeah the other way robs you and it robs
me because I'm not gonna grow and I'm
not gonna grow but now that you're
growing I have to find another way I
have now I have to get graded I'm
already great at the one thing now I got
to get graded another thing now I have
to find other roads now we're both in
this place of exponential growth when we
share when we open source it and that's
the only place I've seen that happening
I mean Elon Musk takes that [ __ ] from
jiu-jitsu
that's what we're doing in jiu-jitsu
we're problem-solving and we're helping
others to get to a place of evolution
and a much faster rate than we ever
could and and that becomes only when
you're when they when the ego goes away
yeah and yeah ego comes up gets
confronted gets smashed all that stuff
happens in there but it's a healthy
playground for it you know yes and and
and it helps in all the ways you know
I've I've I've got a daughter that's 21
years old and she is uh she was adopted
when she was three and I didn't see her
again till she was 12 and then when
she's 17 she reached out again they
there's what a lot of stuff and we talk
all the time now and see each other now
and again and but to tell her something
to say hey man when he [ __ ] what's
these dudes by the time you're 27 here's
what happens she can't believe that cuz
she doesn't know jujitsu right she'd
have to trust a dude that ain't been in
her life out like but I can go easily
with you and say hey you know when you
behave this way it allowed me to take
your back and that's why I strangled you
[ __ ] that happens in two or three
minutes like you can completely unwind
and go oh yeah if I have thrown a
Whizzer in there that would have
happened and so and you can overlay the
microcosm of jiu-jitsu with the
macrocosm of your whole life so if I can
go and do it if you keep [ __ ] with
this company or with this thing or
whatever in ten years this is where that
goes right you see and and and you start
to believe it you start to see systems
and so started to overlay systems and
positions in life when you know like a
lot of guys that are black belts in
jiu-jitsu they've got great technique
and this and that but that's not what
being a black belt really is man if you
can't overlay that [ __ ] into your whole
life you're [ __ ] you're missing the
point man you know and that and there's
there's a whole there's there's levels
to this [ __ ] you know as they say you
know I mean I learned it even just in
you know go into some 12-step stuff that
I start to little things of they are
popping in my life and that's where it
helps me even the most just everyone's
just learning like I differ a little bit
of how to adjust the template that I had
I think it's like getting in touch with
universal truths yeah and then believe
in them and going I'm gonna use the
technique now you know yeah
and instead of going to know the
techniques wrong it's
man if I seen that it's like if you're
if you're not good at a triangle but
you've seen a bunch of other guys be
able to kill really good guys with it
you you go okay maybe you know you don't
be a real [ __ ] crazy just deranged by
your own ego if you go triangle don't
work it's like not a pertinent you have
to admit you suck you're deficient you
don't have skills you're not oh you're
bad at this you haven't done any of the
work you're lazy you have to and once
you can but if you just rhetorical don't
work you know you just walk through that
guy for life and we all know them
sometimes they're able they just get old
but if you're able to go and have that
land on you go it's my responsibility to
make the triangle work well now we have
a place where we can learn and that's
what humility is right being teachable
yeah and so I you know I'm drunk how do
i always break myself back into that so
a lot of humility can be learned through
this I think it's all that you know
you're gonna want humility so get
dominated in the most primal way
possible
by a girl or something just because you
don't know to like there's not much more
that like is a humbling aspect to a guy
where you got to go I don't know
anything I avail myself to the process
to learn or else to go that's gay I'm
outta here you know it's like you're one
or two guys you'd like when confronted
with that you're one or the other I've
been the second guy a lot of points in
my life and I certainly don't want to be
that guy yeah I mean and once you get a
shame to be in the second guy long
enough you go okay I'm not gonna do that
[ __ ] anymore cuz I lose eventually but
the same I just did by just having the
judgement in it serves me for a while
but it's good we get afraid to lose and
then we really lose if we're afraid to
lose but we go ahead and endeavour to
lose anyway then we win it's a weird
thing it's look those paradoxes of life
and you got to have a mind that goes and
goes oh yeah this is completely true
this is opposite of that and it's also
completely true in the same space at the
same time yeah it's like and when you
start to look at life like that you go
okay it's my responsibility everything
is my responsibility the relationships
aren't 5050 there's nothing like it's
all 100% my responsibility you know that
it all lands on me if I want to get
better and the choices do I want to grow
or a stagnation okay with me right you
know and sometimes if you choose tech
nation is okay with you
okay - I've had three huge yeah also
words like that and until that grading
it's just the consequence for me as
higher if I let it go long enough where
that grading in my heart word I say you
dude you could be better you could try
harder you could be you need to start if
I let that go too long I'll destruct
yeah and so I've got to pay I just have
to be sensitive to that for me because
there's high consequences if I if you
don't mind I employed yeah I mean it's
like there's a price to pay that I'm not
willing to accept the cost for yeah not
anymore yeah let's talk about the fight
a little bit oh thanks so much yeah for
you know just having a conversation this
is cool it's been a fun conversation
yeah thanks man it's been really cool
yeah I want to talk to Tony fan your and
how do you feel about hey I you know
watched his whole career and and really
love and admire him and I'm he's a
champion didn't like he's a champ man
and and if anybody is gonna meet beat
that Russian song it should see my hat
so then I look at Brian Ortega who is
also game to fight him and then I look
about the 145 champ coming up the fight
and and that's a bad [ __ ] to
like you know I don't ever wanna count
that guy oh he's a lot like Diego back
in the day you know is how how he lands
on me but but the ground and pound and
you know the last time we saw Norma get
out of fall he fought with such ferocity
that and he's fighting a real G like I
didn't like I was like you're not gonna
grind anybody out at this level because
they were talking about that in the
pre-show they're not he's you know he
grinds a moat and he's gonna wear him
out am I not at this level like with
lesser guys even in that even in the UFC
at that weight level but like not at the
top-ten level guys yeah I'm gonna you're
not gonna grind somebody else make them
quit and take their heart right and then
you watch him do it and I was like that
is a vicious controlling
ground-and-pound of a guy that's just
better at those points of control and
then you know because it's two things to
be able to control like that on the
ground
and keep a man from having his hips get
up and also then that's one thing which
isn't hard to do but that to create an
assault to be able to take one year
limbs to start smashing that same guy
while you're controlling him that's
baffling that's an art man that's hard
and you've got to be so much better than
the guy that you're beating or he has to
be clipped which he's not that's not a
guy that's shaken because you were
devastating on the ground and hit him
with a shot it's cuz you took him down
and you're so much better at controlling
that you can actually control and free
up a limb enough to create horrific
furious nightmarish damage on another
body and and that's at the top level of
the game it's gonna be an exciting fight
is it gonna be an exciting fight I mean
I think it'll be like that it's because
you're gonna see guys that are so
resilient so tough to have really like
nothing to lose like you've got a
[ __ ] going and just savage it out and
guys set themselves free when you watch
guys flail like that that's a beautiful
thing man then when they go out and
they're like no game plan gonna go out
let my training take over and they just
and if they can put that stuff into into
effect I think that's a that's a
tremendous fight to watch but I think
that eventually what happens I mean
because he's not good on his feet right
he's not not the best on his feet
talking about me you know yeah yeah and
and so and I'm I don't know what about
fighting but I've just gotten into yeah
but I'm super curious about how like you
know a guy dropping you know coming in
at the last minute you know what chance
is that is that is there any advantage
to that I mean it's a different you know
the thing is about fighting that it
really rings true is it's a different
guy on it every day I've seen guys that
wear belts that are going I hope I trip
when I fall out when I walk out and I've
trip up the stairs and knocked myself
out and I don't have to fight these are
savage [ __ ] that everybody
loves just cuz the one day wasn't their
day cuz it's just not it's your your
head's not in the same spot every time
you walk out and and so you know who
shows up on fight Dave some guys say you
know Dana says that a lot we'll see who
shows up on fight day and it's like it's
really I mean there's so many different
factors that go like girlfriends died at
weight cut like there's everything that
goes into just where your head are are
you feeling like like like are you
reliving some kind of child like it's
like there's everything that goes into
it it's a head [ __ ] I know guys that
have [ __ ] gone
they've already fought guys and then
started dating that guy's girlfriend and
then sends them pictures while they're
getting their hands wrapped like there's
all kinds of stuff that goes on there's
the dark arts they give it a good
question going back to Tony Ferguson and
our discussion about sunglasses inside
his injury and gives a pass all the time
he was he was doing some press and he
tripped over cords while wearing his
prescription indoor sunglasses so people
were speculating had anything to do with
his sunglasses did yeah if he would had
the little crazy conspiracy theory yeah
he's at Fox Studios right yeah when he
tripped right they did have his
sunglasses on I just found out indoors
which maybe had a compression shirt on -
I don't know however here in Fox Studios
and you're one of the most savage
athletes like people wouldn't think that
it was crazy if they saw you just
[ __ ] running through a jungle and
swinging vine to vine and grabbing a
bamboo and ripping it throw it out and
just going on like you're that kind of
animal yeah right and in training stuff
happens guys bow their knees oh there's
guys I mean you know I've been in where
everybody's wrestling we're doing shoot
boxing or something and somebody shoots
and then another couple goes into him
that guy's got a fight but now his knees
below no like like I've seen a lot of
horrible accidents happen at the wrong
time all that but you're in a TV studio
and then you've hurt yourself tripping
on a cord where it blows your knee out
to that did that happen
or is there an overlord that's going you
know what you move away from this one
we're gonna put him here and then you're
gonna do I don't know what goes on
behind the scenes there right that all
is black magic to me do you mean like
over
where could be something like hey here's
an envelope Tony right your knees hurt
right now okay as you leave the UFC
presser at Fox Studios where it's a
completely controlled environment and
you're not doing any fitness at all and
so your knees hurt here's your envelope
and then just we're gonna take care of
you but it's gonna be three fights from
now Wow or so I don't know
I like that theory because max Holloway
who is stepping in to face khabib on six
days notice he was scheduled on UFC 222
in early March to fight Frankie Edgar
and he dropped out with an injury
now it's khabib verse max Holloway and
either winner sets up that mega fight
with Conor that's off in the distance so
I really like that theory I don't know
it just dawned on me yesterday I was
like this strikes me as a little fun I
have a gun I don't know or anything and
I don't think that any of these people
are dishonest and right this is
entertainment yeah this is what I'm
saying these are all men of Honor for
sure and I hope that the best thing is
happening for everybody but that just
dawned on me is a little funny I thought
well maybe something is afoot has do you
feel like the UFC and the different
organizations have turned a little bit
more into like a WWE s I mean they're
just what looking where the money is and
I think right a beautiful thing about
that is is that you see that actual real
fights garner big money and also I think
that we as athletes I add myself in that
very loosely but like if you're if
you're an active athlete that is that is
taken a paycheck from the UFC in
particular right now I think what we're
seeing is how much actual money the UFC
and these fight organizations are making
I mean when they can talk about the idea
that they're gonna come off of a half a
billion dollars for an MMA fight purse
for a single bout I mean when
historically under 2 million pays every
fighter on a card of 20 fights well or
something you know what I mean it's like
so like how much money was actually
always in the cut really like it cuz
boxing is blowing it out like this like
and they don't have the viewership that
we do what's going on for real though
yeah and uh and I think that all that
stuff they were coming into a leveling
where you know guy guys are gonna be
able to help more than ever
and and I'm not one of these guys that's
got sour grapes about they're so cheap
and this and ever I'm not that guy at
all I'm just saying like it just gets
more fair people did they built they
built the platform that everybody's
standing on man like [ __ ] honor that
respect your [ __ ] yeah that respect were
respect what was available because these
men the Lorenzo and Frank Fertitta and
Dana White put themselves on the line
with big dollars to be able to make a
platform like this that made our sport
man they they did that you know Bellator
didn't do that the king of the cage
didn't do that pride didn't
none of these you know they did that and
and so for a bunch of us that we're
gonna be you know shipping clerks or
[ __ ] janitors or you know
schoolteachers or dancers or lawyers or
dancers maybe you know who knows what
happens take a turn at the circus to be
able to go and get an exposure like that
for doing a thing that I was doing for
free you know that guys that everybody
that was a fighter that had that heart
there was something that we had to find
out about ourselves it wasn't about a
job it was a passion man it was a real
passion and so I think that like I just
give thanks to that wherever it is I
never want to sound like I'm disloyal or
feel like there's so seem like that
about that I got nothing but admiration
for that whole group and and because I
and I say that because you know they
paid poorly for a long time they paid
two grand and two grand and but you know
there's a building thing and they got to
create solvency in your business so
anyway that's my disclaimer yeah yeah
I'm sure after you've probably learned a
lot about business after you got into
business yeah absolutely and kind of see
it able to see things from different
side which I'm sure has been really
interesting it is yeah I mean it's you
know I guess yeah it's like I can't
imagine what that's like to be in at
certain levels of things and then to
have it
I'm sure it's kind of like the same with
like guys like Dusty Rhodes I'm not to
put you know you and any wild age
bracket or anything but you know Ric
Flair's or Dusty Rhodes are the big boss
when you look at like wrestlers that I
watched growing
who weren't getting paid top like you
know probably what the they don't write
a couple they're really like Hulk Hogan
of that era
maybe the Iron Sheik yeah then like
there's only a few guys that probably
really got really got on it yeah
but even before that like Kerry Von
Erich like those guys you know and then
you look now when these guys are it's a
lot more polished they're not even
fighting as hard it's a little bit
different you know do you think the
fighting has always been as hard or do
you think it's harder than ever in
wrestling or no yes sorry in wrestling
as prior has been about the same and and
in the UFC is hard yes it's always been
a pinnacle level event and that looks
different from year to year because
there's eras to the [ __ ] right and so a
guy that solvent and a top-10 guy 10
years ago is not gonna be even a very
good amateur today right kind of thing
and and so like you look at the the
level of exponential growth and
evolution of the athlete of the
abilities and athletic abilities of the
athlete where we're getting athletes
from also now you've got a real viable
income base where if I'm a real
[ __ ] as athlete like LeBron
James
yeah and I'm walking on to a d1
basketball group or football or
something like that and I can do that I
can go towards that and I could maybe
maybe I could get picked up for a few
years and nothing maybe get a pension in
the NFL or something like now you you
you go and you look at that whatever
that is I don't know they pay those guys
every year or you go I could go and I
could actually become a superstar why
cuz you know what I mean I'm fast I'm
strong and I'm able to learn or all
those old high level wrestlers now if
you're a wrestler if you're a kid and
you're one of these d-level rust like if
if you were a d1 wrestler and you went
into the Olympics or or the world games
or anything that's the end man yeah and
now you go in and you're that good you
don't even have to be that good but if
you're that good and you have a
ferocious heart and mind that is able to
now learn how to dance on your toes
instead of being flat-footed or like all
that kind of thing man you're you're the
savage and now there's a real place for
you
actual paid sports yeah and so I think
the level of athlete were aggregating
better athletes as opposed to dudes that
just came off and had a willingness to
express themselves that way yeah and I
think that that's what's happening and
now there used to be athletes that would
just really party really hard and only
be in shape for certain times and then
as as we're aging like Randy Couture
said a great thing about it where he'd
said you know I don't get in shape for
fights cuz they asked him how long you
gonna take to get in shape for this way
since I don't I have to stay in shape at
my age only difference between me as a
45 year old and 25 year old that I'm
gonna fight is that he could get in
shape in a couple months for a fight I
have to stay in shape because the
getting in shape it's too much of a
process like there's no skill right it's
easier to maintain it right so I have to
maintain it if I want my skills to get
higher and most fighters then used to do
that too and I had a you know talk with
Michelle Waterson a while ago she'd
[ __ ] come off a win and and but then
it's like you know I said you know we
get in these positions where there's
these guys and they they get into great
shape and then they they fall and they
have pizza afterwards for a [ __ ]
three months okay
and with that as a that's a way to
behave good because you get depressed
after you fight no matter what and it
comes down and then you have some
freedom and you take all the tight
controls off but like imagine if you
just mitigated the time when you went
into the hole and you let your weight go
to control and you didn't have to get in
shape again because the next time that
phone call comes and you have to start
getting in shape well if you got two
months you'll spend a few weeks getting
into shape dialing your weight in you'll
be worrying about other [ __ ] what if you
took those words away because you knew
that just by just starting to do
two-a-days again your weight would come
down naturally and cuz you never went so
crazy with it your cardio never got out
of shape because you always paid
attention to it because your lifestyle
was it's your [ __ ] job to be a fighter
now this is what you do right if this is
your mechanism are you not gonna keep it
oiled and polished all the time because
if you're not the difference between you
and a champion is they are you're never
gonna get there you'll be the person
they step over
because the champion nowadays cannot be
the guy that's taking that time off to
do cocaine or do this or that and I mean
there's there's outliers but there's the
Jon Jones I think that John is is able
to come in at whatever like well hailer
yeah he's still able to but it's like
that you're gonna point to one anomaly
the aggregate of the guys of the people
of the athletes you're gonna have to
maintain that and that and that's where
it's going so it's getting to be where
you know you just can't catch up where
the median level is so high it's so high
yeah nine even knows have a comedy like
a lot of the best comedians an hour
sober know or don't drink or never got
into it whereas it used to be a tool
that people would use to probably get
more creative in wild onstage for a
while now it's becoming less than and
they use it for an excuse oh I was so
stoned on stage I was so drunk or
whatever yeah oh I'm sorry I've had too
many drinks sir yeah I know it's like
people use that as their gimmick you
know it's like I'm gonna see the kind of
drunk guy up there again and he'll have
his cocktail and and and it's like
that's that's a gimmick I mean and it's
like right that's good comedy in a way
but it's like there's other comedy that
I appreciate more you know than that
right and do you are you creating the
best environment for you know for the
best you to grow in yeah yeah you can't
discipline yourself if you're gonna get
loose a lot um going back real quick to
the fight do you think that that's
happened before ever that they that
there's been like fights fights that
have been paid to be pushed certain ways
percent yeah why is that happening now I
don't know I mean I'm just thinking
about the environment you know I believe
it has happened already
I believe it's happened at least twice
which fights the only one I'll say that
I believe that it's happened at least
once is that there's a time when pride
got bought by the UFC and pride was a
big Japanese fight organization probably
the premier known as the most savage
fighters in the world like if you were
to say on a grading who was more
talented UFC fighters or pride fighters
and there wasn't a lot of crossover for
some time you would say the pride
fighters are the best in the world
UFC is a strong second and the USC
bought them there was some crossover
but eventually the Yakuza I think it
just disbanded you know it was a it was
a done deal at a certain point and the
FC owned all the contracts from all the
pride fighters so they would get guys
they got to know the errors that way
they probably owned Bob Sapp they got
Heath Herring a bunch of dudes right so
then there was a fight and Heath Herring
fought Nogueira I believe is what it was
and it was I think it was up in San Jose
maybe and anyway
you watch the fight happen and inside it
might have been in the first round and
not laid in with a couple of shots and
and knocked down Heath and then maybe
he'd knocked him down and got scared I
think that he was gonna knock him out
and Yente throw another punch the whole
round like he didn't go to finish him
and I was thought that's super odd for a
fighter he didn't throw a strike
the whole second round and then he I'm
like I feel like Heath Herring bet
against himself and through a fight just
now against not it's it's like that's
it's like it seemed like as a viewer
that's what I was watching but I don't
know like yeah look at the vibe you get
as a viewer then then there's guys in a
camp that I that there was that talk
about but you know that stuff sneaks in
I think what's more prevalent prize is
judges you know cuz if you like like if
you were to pay like a Nick Diaz and
McGregor if you're gonna pay either one
of those guys to do something in a fight
like whatever it is they've got such a
game competitiveness a savagery in that
intention of destruction of their
opponent that even if they agreed to all
that when they got in that precise
moment when and and when there's a fin
when you can finish it when you can
alter it all right
they're gonna take that because they're
trigger pullers man those guys so like
you can't pay that guy right - you can't
count on him but you can count on the
judge yeah and the judge will do what
you say every time and so you just tell
the judge and [ __ ] you know that's a
much safer way that's what I figured I
figure those guys just get a check for
here's 100 grand and it's gonna go like
this and I cuz you could guarantee that
those get the fighters are well that's a
wild card to try to convince a fighter
to do a thing you know coming from a man
who's been there what about a thug roses
you have another shot oh yeah baby
that's my girl I was her she's maybe my
favorite consciousness and the whole UFC
moon
she's something beautiful that one yeah
I think that I really I really admire
the way she carries herself
regardless through her whole career
through victories defeats all of that
you know I love that you know she's like
one of the most physically beautiful
people walking the earth really and then
and she saw that and she's like I don't
want to be like there's a handful other
girls that are really you know part of
their thing is that they're the
beautiful girls in the UFC
you know they there's there's a couple
of those like that they're really
gorgeous not that everybody's not
beautiful blah blah blah and she she
just shaves her head she's like I'm not
I'm not gonna play this game you know
and I'm gonna play a different game
because the reasons I'm here are
different then for attention and fame
you know and I think that there's
something I mean I really I admire the
Hat go to her and the way she they're
just the way she carries herself she's
such an inspiration and such a mark of
dignity and somebody that by the way
their walk here's what it is by the way
that she walks and behaves I know that
she's sacrificing money and fame I know
that she is I know that it's a
calculator will net recover him in the
way she does and she [ __ ] does it
anyway
Wow you know that's how I feel about her
it's you know so as far as her I'm like
I'm I'm a real fan and that like and I
think she can do anything and I think
that that's that's a woman that has got
success ingrained in her in a way that
whether the fight you know we're
watching life happen on screen or
wherever whether it's movies or fights
or whatever we're seeing what public
figures you know guys that are
commentator like all that we're watching
this [ __ ] happened live and you might be
watching all losses and it's all
overlaying the next
which will also be a loss - when
overlaid over the next it's like we're
playing this game a hop scotch I'm like
I'm gonna try my best knowing that this
is all just practice for tomorrow mmm no
matter what it is if it's the Super Bowl
today this is an opportunity I can get
better right now today for the next
thing also I can't think about the next
thing ever it's that paradox you got to
live in I got to have it all into this
fight right now this is the only thing I
could think about and also this doesn't
mean anything all this is there's a next
step into my tomorrow hmm you know so it
means everything and it doesn't mean
anything all at the same time and like
and when you start to live in those
paradoxes you go I've got to have a
higher faith in the universe yeah
because something else is going on out
here and so a matter is the money matter
does know none of that matters it's how
I walk and carry myself that matters you
know and some people are real true
example Rosa great it's a great name
yeah it's such a great embodiment of
that actually mm-hmm you know of what
you're saying like using yourself yeah
she's a consciousness that you can see
just by the way she walks if you have
any awareness at all do you who does max
Holloway have a chance to oh yeah man
yeah dude that yeah though really is a
real Hawaiian fighters dude they I mean
to me it's like northern New Mexicans
and Hawaiians they've got I never bet
against there's a savagery there and max
is so good everywhere - I mean it's like
like Tony he's like a smaller version of
Tony I think in a way you know Ferguson
I think it's it's a good it's it's a
good overlay in that kind of a fight and
that's that's a savage Mattel you hear
what he said when he got offered the
fight by his manager mm-hmm he goes [ __ ]
yeah he says this is how legends are
built Wow or something to that effect
this is the kind of this is legend [ __ ]
this is he sees an opportunity
[ __ ] this fight I see this as an
opportunity to be a god to be a legend
right now and it's amazing goosebumps
yeah somebody asked me if I can go to
the mall tomorrow I'm like ah look at my
schedule I'm serious no I don't know
that I have time yeah it's like man I
don't know see I mean I get another
phone call not that you're not important
but somebody else calls not going to the
mall with ya and so then who knows what
playing I'm missing out on that a bear
that a higher power could have looking
for me trip man I need you here to get
you here all the ways that I
contrived my life to be would have left
me so it's such a corny thing to say but
it's so it would love me so short I
could not have have built my life the
way it is by looking at outcome all I
could do is dig into the work that was
in front of me
and leave the outcome as it is all I can
trust all I can move the dial on is the
work I do right the work I do the
excellence and the honor and integrity
that I put into the work that I'm doing
in present that's all I can do to worry
about what the outcomes gonna be good
dude it will be if that's the way I
honor the work yeah if I'm worried about
the outcome though guess what I'm not
doing on the ground or in the work man I
love it so that's all there is I do the
work I leave the results up to the
universe man in my life shines and if I
get that twisted the universe never
doesn't even [ __ ] work at all and I'm
alone isolated in my room it's dark and
I don't feel like I'll ever get over
this hole yeah so I just got to know my
role and I got to play that you know and
if you know if you're out there
listening you don't believe that exists
in you I I just um I'm not trying to
judge what I think you're wrong I think
sometimes we don't cater to those parts
of us and it takes a while to build
those muscles and I'm not saying that I
do it but I am saying that I when I sit
here and listen to you and have this
conversation that I believe more that I
can
it sure is worth considering yeah that
may be it's a great possibility it's
surely no because when I got tired of
going hey man I keep going down the same
[ __ ] Road the same consciousness the
same [ __ ] feels like fire that's
burning that's propelling me down the
same and I end up with the same shitty
called a sack of loneliness every time
the guy goes maybe consider taking a
different route and then he offers me a
route and I go okay and eventually I get
so sick of that then I go it's via
negativa right the negative way that's
how most of us learn yeah and and and
and so if you're if you're balls-deep
and completely the wrong thing awesome
man
cuz that's part of the process to get
into the right thing you know that's
what I think yeah man it's uh I mean I
could talk to you forever we'll talk
about another time yeah we'll do it
another time
remember though Theo came in coffee cold
we'll get you 15% off for like the next
month yeah let's do that man and we'll
share that on all of our elements and
you can follow tape Fletcher
áit FLE tche are on Instagram and almost
anywhere yeah the fine and good luck
working on the book man thanks dude yeah
it's exciting thanks for being here bro
all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]